Oh, whoops.
I was getting into making my schedule for the week, so.
I lost track of time.
Oh, let me fix the chat.
Welcome in everybody!
Minto cuteo!
What about...
Minto sweeto?
Minto...
Evil...
Minto SpaghettiOs!
Minto...
She's sweeto too?
Minto savorio?
SpaghettiO...
Oh, hiyao gozaiimasu!
Wow, we're back!
Today, we got five missions left.
Ace Combat.
Four.
No, happy hunting minto.
Thank you!
Thank you, Tony!
Thank you for two years!
Sweeto, sweeto!
I want some spaghetti.
delicious but please don't admit to them what kind of things
can you add mint to I know you can add it to like certain
drinks I feel like mint is not as versatile as a as an herb
as other things chocolate that's true tea oh tea lamb I've
never heard of mint and lamb Why?
Should I get a lamb outfit?
That would be so cute.
Haymito the Phantom Ace Pilot yesterday was my birthday!
What?
I missed your birthday!
I'm so sorry!
Happy birthday!
Blue Eyes Hunter Dragon!
After watching your last stream, I figured out why you
struggled with dropping the bomb.
It was because I had something to do with a bomb called
BDSP, which is a bomb spread.
Extremely hard to use, even for me.
as a veteran that's what people were saying yeah hello
welcome
back and jelly is used for lamb a lot i'm gonna get a lamb
outfit i'm gonna write that down it'll be a long time from
now like a cute little wait it'll be so cute lamb outfit
mountain lamb lamb lamb lamb lamb the ice hunter dragon
happy birthday i hope that's so nice having a birthday on
the weekend.
I hope you had a nice nice day yesterday.
One second.
Hold on.
I just got a...
I just got a message.
Hold on.
One second.
Okay.
Thank you!
Yo, Aibo.
I'm not, I'm not, I'm not, I'm not, I'm a ghost actually.
Danger zone, or danger zoning.
Today, guys, my brain, I feel like is all over the place.
This is an extremely packed week for me.
So I apologize in advance if my brain is scattered to the
masses.
Um, I will be, uh, going to Japan.
uh this week but I will have a let's plays of the wolf among
us that will be five episodes while I'm gone so I have to
record that but um but um oh my gosh I was gonna do the
Walking Dead season 2 so I was like you know what I kind of
was in the mood for like a really story heavy thing last
time I did a let's play it was portal And that's very
puzzly, which is very awesome.
I love I love me a good puzzle game But I was like, oh, I'm
kind of in the mood for like a story something Do you know
when he'll be back?
I'll be back on the 15th So last stream for the week will be
the 6th and then I have an off collab on Friday with Den
Satsu I bow I boo same thing exactly off collab on friday
and then saturday starting saturday will be wolf among us
yeah yeah yeah um and i'll be back the 15th wait 15th or
16th 15th maybe wait i can't remember um
but oh my gosh i was gonna do i I recorded The Walking Dead
for two hours yesterday.
Which, like, was as busy as I am at the moment.
I was like, okay, cool.
I'm gonna get...
I'm gonna start my Let's Play.
We're gonna get...
We're gonna...
Do good stuff.
That game is just...
Absolute Misery Simulator.
It just is so...
Absolutely...
like we're gonna make you feel bad no matter what
i got tone on my i'm a certified freak for real man
speaking of dancing to the concert yesterday i was traveling
with so much fun thanks for the east side of the continent
thank you i'm glad you had fun that where my international
job placed me.
I'm moving to Kobe!
May 19th!
Oh my gosh!
How about...
Wait, that's...
Oh my gosh, that's soon!
Good luck with your move!
Wow.
It's a lot to take until you get a breather of hope.
I'm gonna just tell you guys what happens.
Because it's so...
I was like...
It sucks because there was like some funny moments when I
recorded.
but whatever.
The story quality dropped so bad after season one.
I couldn't remember what everybody mentioned if it was like
later episodes, later seasons or whatever.
So I was like, oh, I checked the reviews and they said
overwhelmingly positive on Steam.
So I was like, oh, it's probably this one is fine.
And then, oh my god.
So it ends off season one with your hanging out with two
people from season one at the start of season two.
For some reason, they let poor Clementine go into a room by
herself.
Why would you do that?
They were like, oh yeah, go, go, go to the bathroom.
We're not going to help you check to make sure there's
zombies or anything in there.
No, no.
Just go in by yourself, little kid.
She goes in there.
She drops her water bottle, and when she does, some other
random person walks into the bathroom.
And she had, Clementine had left her gun on the sink.
I've ranted about this several times already.
I was like, I was like, she left, she leaves it, and some
random girl walks in and takes her gun.
And it's just like, I know somebody, I know you're in there.
I know you're in there.
And so she opens the door.
And then one of the people, it's, what are the two people,
the guy walks in?
And he's like trying to be quiet, trying to defuse the, like
trying to help Clementine out.
noise and the random girl turns around and shoots him and
kills that guy in like the first 10 minutes omid kills him
in the first 10 minutes of the game blackboard welcome to
membership thank you for no reason nothing and then the girl
and then Krista his wife walks in and the the her so it was
like an absolute pointless death it was just so stupid i was
like okay um and no so then it's just christa and clementine
and they get ambushed by a group of people and clementine
tries to help out or she like runs away there's like there
are groups of people pursuing clementine for no good reason
just aggressive to be aggressive clementine falls river and
like it's swept downstream she's all by herself now oh my
gosh what is a what it's like it's like fall or something it
really is just bad writing it makes me so mad and so she
comes across a dog and i was like oh my gosh dog yay and
then i was like oh no dog animal in in i don't i wouldn't
consider walking dead a horror game but dog in
post-apocalyptic this kind of scenario i was like oh no oh
no and the dog is like a little standoffish at first but
they play catch and the dog she's like petting the dog and
it's fine and everything's fine rip walking dead guy he got
here with a bazooka kaboom kaplow so you know you find like
photo of the of the family that lived at this campsite where
the dog is at and like they had the dog and you know you're
looking for food, you're hungry and my thing in this game is
do hold on, hold on you find you find a can of beans and you
open it and you start eating it and one of the options for
the dog like there's a couple options for the dog it's like
the dog is like begging at you and you're like oh don't beg
or i'll give you the leftovers or you can feed the dog i fed
the dog because why not i'm going to feed the dog and the
dog no reason the dog literally like flips a switch and
literally starts mauling clementine Loses it and you are
having to punch the dog in the face as it's mauling your arm
You're grabbing the can of beans and like slapping it like
Serious like oh my god.
It's actually like what the hell is this?
No reason for the dog to be Aggressive like this then you
push the dog And you push the dog away like you finally get
it to let go of your arm and and it lands on these spikes at
the campsite that was like the tent was broken and it lands
on the broken tent and so it is now impaled and it is
whimpering and like suffering on the go I was like this is
so horrible for no reason pointless tragedy the game yes
exactly and i was just like oh my gosh i don't want to hear
this dog suffering anymore so i mercy kill it but they force
they make you do it yourself like they're like okay here's
the here's the okay now press the right button to kill the
dog and i'm like this is this is actually so terrible and
you know you could argue the dog was so hungry yeah the dog
was also the dog got aggressive because it wanted the food
but do squirrels not exist in this game like rabbits or or
or anything else like the dog could it not could it could it
not hunt for itself like ghost cutie thank you so much for
the tangy thing so girls she did feed i did feed the dog And
he's not aggressive!
Gotta wonder what was in those beans.
For real!
And also, it made me realize, like, why are zombies so
hungry for human flesh?
Why don't they ever go after animals?
What's the difference?
If they're just hungry for flesh, for meat, why don't
they...
Got me thinking.
They do in some lore.
Oh, do they?
Okay.
Well, it's very...
Obviously, you can't really tell.
Not always seeing what zombies are doing, but...
Depends on the universe.
Oh, okay, okay.
Humans just taste so delicious.
Sorry, I had to rant about that.
Because last night, I was like...
You popped up in my suggestions.
Ace Combat 4 was one of my...
Not hand me down games.
Ace Combat 5, unsung warren.
sunborn next yes we will do five next thank you so much cam
for the super chat thank you okay i'm done ranting i'm done
ranting and hooting and hollering
i'm done hooting and hollering about the walking dead season
two so i will not be playing it or the rest of the series i
was like also then what am i i like the character and he
died and I got blamed for it.
I was like, I'm done.
I can't do it anymore.
I was so mad.
I was like, what do you mean it's my fault?
Nine minute cannibalism rush.
Okay, so would you like some beans?
Foaming at the mouth for the beans.
That recording is now lost to me.
Yeah, it actually is.
Oh.
Yeah.
I remember I stopped.
I stopped recording and then I just like put my face in my
hands and I was like.
Because I felt like I had wasted two hours of my time.
Release the being footage.
Not.
I didn't want you guys to have to watch that.
That was brutal.
That was just not good.
I'm going to sound stupid, but what exactly was the problem
with the game?
Um, it was, I really am weak to animal violence like that.
So it just left like a super bad taste in my mouth.
And I realized that the game just felt like...
It was just so miserable for the sake, for just, like, you
know, I understand what these kinds of things, like, to
progress a story, like, things need to happen, right?
Like, we can't have five months of, or, like, five episodes
of Clementine living, living peacefully on a farm.
You know what I mean?
Like, I get it.
But it is just, it is just bad thing after bad thing after
bad thing.
Like, oh, my god.
The dog?
It just felt like the dog became aggressive for no reason.
Maggie, no!
Decide between suffering option one or two.
The outcome will be the same.
Either way.
Gameplay!
Yeah, exactly.
That's how Walking Dead beat is.
Yeah, like, my goodness.
Ugh.
And of course, the ending isn't worth it since there's more
games.
I hear that the last game, it has a decent, or is decent,
but I'm not willing to go through the rest.
So that's okay.
I at least played season one, and I like that.
Even though it was also very...
It wasn't... It didn't feel as...
I don't know.
It's just the fact that a main character died in the first
10 minutes, and then the dog.
And then everything else...
Everybody acted so stupid.
Oh!
The next thing is you get rescued by some people afterwards,
and they're like, we have a doctor.
They'll take a look at your bite wound because they could
not tell.
They were like, oh gosh, you're bitten.
Are you, is it a zombie?
She was like, no, it's a dog.
It's a dog.
And they're like, we have a doctor.
We'll take you to the doctor to look at the bite wound and
verify if it's a dog wound or not.
They take him to the doctor and he's like, I can't tell.
What do you mean?
What?
He just shrugs.
He literally looks at it for two seconds and is like...
Could be anything.
I'm a doctor, not a mechanic.
This is like...
A good doctor, just a doctor.
Oh, it was just, uh...
Wow.
It's like so silly.
Everything felt too silly for me to be like, I can't...
Like, it was so silly and also, like, so depressing that I
was like, Am I supposed to be laughing here?
Am I supposed to be...
You know?
What tone am I supposed to take?
But anyway, we have five missions to do.
Today, we will beat H-Convict 4!
Yippee!
So let's load up.
Oh.
Okay, they're the same time.
Mission 14.
Wait a second.
Oh, wait, it's 18 missions.
I thought for some reason, I was like, wait, I thought it
was 16 missions.
Load.
um oh my gosh I was like looking into stuff about like
Mobius 1 a little bit this guy is like the guy he actually
is John Ace Combat um three more ground missions okay thank
you for the warning Mobius 1 what's kind of fun is like You
know, he's so legendary.
And, like, I feel cool playing as him.
Does that make sense?
When I play as Snake in Metal Gear, and they're like, the
legendary solid snake, but I'm running around like a
buffoon, I don't feel like I am the legendary solid.
I feel like a...
But, but, Mobius 1, I feel good.
It's cool.
Melanie, thank you so much for the Valkyrie.
It was great to meet you all.
Oh, shit.
Oh, blink.
Thank you.
Glad you like the snake cosplay.
Heard that scream when I left.
The concert was an amazing experience too.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Yes, I love the snake.
Love the cosplay.
It was the face of the series for a long time.
Yeah, I believe it.
Mmm.
Mobius 1.
Too cool.
Are you cool?
Do you ever want to play another Telltale-like game?
The Dark Pictures games are so stupid.
Oh, I love the Dark Pictures games.
Oh my gosh, they are very stupid and fun.
Yeah.
Yeah, I saw he appeared, yeah, four, five.
Yeah, in VR and seven.
Like, I watched someone play the VR mission as Mobius 1 and
7.
I can't I'm like, I want to try it, but I'm also I'm I'm I'm
scared Oh my goodness But he's so cool Yeah, I feel so cool
playing as him So Continue Breaking arrows, mission 14 What?
These combat 7 VR air...
Air show?
In response, the illusions have launched large numbers of
cruise missiles against the ISAF landing forces.
Our radar is unable to pick up these missiles that are at
ultra-low altitude.
Failure to destroy these missiles will put our troops in
danger.
Missiles.
Your mission is to shoot and destroy every cruise missile.
Okay.
Cruise missile.
No data.
Do you intend to do Project Wingman?
Maybe eventually.
I think it'd be fine too.
We have any new aircraft.
No.
So what would be good for this?
Full anti-air.
I mean they're missiles so they're in the air, right?
something fast whoa okay okay so like this guy look up
yellow 13 more after this how are you
what is wait what do I have already wait Eurofighter is
great for this I'm oh wait could I buy it actually I didn't
check I was just about to go sell whatever I had
Thank you for coming to worship like yesterday.
I was nervous like for my first time ever being green boy.
You guys made it such a memorable experience.
I'm glad you enjoyed all the dances.
The chikawas be made.
Thank you.
Thank you, baby.
Thank you for coming to see us.
Thank you.
The chikawas were perfection.
We were all like freaking out about them.
They were so stinking cute.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for the hot guys so far.
Thank you!
Oh, I can't afford it.
Hold on.
What do I have?
Oh, don't.
Oh, just
this one.
Sorry.
It was so hard to tell.
It was so bright.
All right, here we go.
F-14 is good this mission, too.
Hmm.
F-14.
That was...
Nope.
Oh, my gosh.
15.
Ugh.
Wait, I thought I- wait, was I- was I not on 15?
Wait, I can't read!
F14.
Oh, yes, yes!
Let's try this one though.
Wait, where'd it go?
This one.
The Eurofighter.
Turn down the lights!
I know I'm like squinting in here.
Let's try this one.
I think the hero fighter might be if I need fast and air.
Multi-lock missiles, good in this mission.
Good to know!
Air to ground, just kidding.
Okay, go away.
Go away, go away.
Well, what do I...
Let's quit.
Multi-target air to air!
Exactly what I need!
Destroy all indicated targets.
I'm scared.
Oh, it's night time.
Mobius 1.
A wire from the Northern Landing Forces.
We're depending on your efforts.
Me.
Commence operation.
Don't let any escape.
Okay.
Oh.
We're going to have to...
You're going to have to bear with me as I get used to the
controls again.
Oh.
Where is it?
Oh, there, oh, oh, oh, oh, I see it.
Did I take them all out?
Miss!
Uh-oh, shoot.
Is that the moon?
Wait, maybe from behind is easier.
Destroy it.
Do another.
I'm going!
How am I supposed to...
Oh.
60 miles and closing.
Mobius 1 shot down a target.
Yes, I did.
What is that over there?
There's a tiny little die.
You see that?
I'm headed to east.
Bonus target.
Oh, I see.
Oh.
Eh.
That's not going to make...
Holy cow, there's so many!
Oh, my God!
Ah!
Uh...
Give me a second.
Err.
Where'd they go?
Oh, gosh.
I only have...
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Let's do this.
That's a lot of missiles.
Yeah, I think I messed up.
I think I'll have to redo this.
That's okay, though.
I'm going fast.
I'm getting there.
They're like always lower than I expect, you know.
The target split into two!
Oh, what?
Wait, why did they do that?
Why did they do that?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, where'd they... Where'd they go?
Holy cow.
Wait, where'd they go?
They're so fast!
Where did they go?
How did they take off so fast?
Oh my gosh.
We're totally not going to beat this one.
That's okay, though.
Please lock in.
Give me tone.
Yeah, but the other one.
Oh my gosh.
It just...
30 miles and closing.
Ah!
Oh, please.
I like end up going too slow I got it, okay I get it, yeah
It is like a chase scene, holy cow Go, go, go, go, go, go,
go But the other ones, will I even be able to keep up Will I
be able to track them back down Oh no, they're like right
there Wait, no they're not Oh, oh, oh, I'm going down there
20 miles Okay, all right.
Oh, okay.
All right, all right.
Meow.
I want to be behind them.
I wish to...
Oh, are they like...
Am I crazy?
Where?
How are they?
Are they like turning directions?
Am I crazy?
Okay.
All right.
We're behind them now.
I think.
Ah!
This is advisable.
Oh, I have lost it.
Uh...
Where is it?
This way?
There are two left.
Two left, two left, two left.
I don't know if I'll make it.
They're ten miles away.
That's so... That's... That's not very far, I think.
They're so fast.
Ah, yeah, yeah.
Ay, ay, ay, ay, ay.
Maybe?
Oh, shit.
No.
Please.
Where'd he go?
Oh, there.
Okay.
Come on.
Oh, shit!
Ah!
No way!
We were so close!
We've lost sight of the cruise missile.
Abort mission.
The missile knows where it is.
Don't speak.
okay that's okay though i'll have the uh i won't waste the
other ones this time okay this is fine is one a wire from
the northern landing forces we're depending on this is it's
fine we were warming up we were warming up don't let any
escape the one that got away
and they're and they end up being lower i think than i like
around 4 000 feet target is closing in on the landing site
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna go right And then...
But I don't want to like, you know...
Hoi!
There we go.
Yeah, baby!
Where are they?
I went this way.
Not so difficult, thank you!
Thank you for the five good,
dude.
Uh, hold on.
I'm like not...
Wait.
Oh, there they are.
Is that the Aurora Borealis?
Okay.
Come on.
come on destroy destroy destroy oh shoot I missed the here
we'll go after these ones first nice I got something let's
go okay come on come on come on give me tone come on they're
so fast
How are they turning?
Come on, please!
Oh, shit.
Damn it.
I'm gonna...
Wait.
Let it pass me.
Or it's not gonna do that.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, where'd it go?
Where'd it go?
How is it turning?
How are you turning?
Who's controlling this thing?
Boom and boom.
Yes!
Oh my gosh.
How?
Who's controlling this thing?
Not me.
No, I mean the missile.
Who's controlling this missile?
Uh, where's the other ones, actually?
This way.
Is it just the one?
What?
30 miles and closing.
I don't know if that'll reach, actually.
Oh!
Oh, there's more.
I see that.
Yes, one.
Another aircraft has been sighted.
Yeah, I see.
That's strange.
There's only one.
The cruise missile is heading south along the glacier.
Looks like a regular warhead, but keep your distance.
My distance?
Wait, what do you mean my distance?
Real mission begins?
What do you mean by that?
It seems slow?
Azure, welcome to bamboo shop.
Thank you.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, never mind.
What's it doing?
Randos?
them I ignore you I'm going supersonic speed wait
where is it that that holy hell oh my god okay oh where'd it
go up above me she's so hot no no no I don't care about you
wait where the hell did it go why did it lock on the person
oh my god no no no no this is bad this is bad this is bad
this is bad oh shit it I didn't change targets but for some
reason there it is okay
miss how is it so speedy like how is it actually zipping
around me it's turning every which way my altitude how is it
turning so fast yeah it's jukein for real oh
my gosh you're not a missile what are you oh no no no okay
oh my god how is it even getting close we're just We're just
going everywhere.
What do you mean 40 miles?
Have we even gone anywhere?
Okay.
It's in my sight.
Finally.
Oh my god.
It's zipping and zooming.
I just...
How am I supposed to hit this thing?
Acting like this.
Holy hell.
Ah!
Leave me alone!
Where did it go?
Please!
Oh my god!
Oh, sorry I'm all over the place.
Holy...
Oh, okay.
Please.
I need to be faster.
Or something.
Oh.
No, there's no sticking way.
There's no way.
Oh my gosh.
Where is she?
Please, please, please.
There, there.
Please.
Yeah!
What an explosion.
Mission complete.
The landing forces saw from below and they extend their
thanks.
Yes!
Yeah!
I'm so stinking sweaty.
Holy cow.
That was a real close.
We were so close to the line.
This is stress the mission.
Oh, I had a feeling.
I was like, I think the missile.
I was like, when I shot those last two, I was like, I feel
like, I feel like that might have been it.
Good job.
There was no unnecessary loss of landing troops.
Yay!
And the landing coast is now secure.
Yippee!
Oh, glad I could help.
Yes, thank you, Eurofighter.
I mean, Eurocanalar.
Thank you!
For the super jet.
Lost missile.
Response to Pookie.
What?
Pookie?
Plus rewarded round.
Can't believe they actually put not in the game.
You think that missile was pain?
Try doing it with guns only, because that's what Ace Combat
2 had you do.
This thing was zipping.
How was it zipping and zooming so much?
Thank you guys for the super chads!
Yellow 13 has nothing on this missile pilot.
Drunk it 14.
Ugh.
As the allies advanced, forces from the east filled our
town.
The AA gun crew set up their positions atop the hospital,
and Yellow 13 smoldered with quiet anger over their tactics.
Smoldered.
Nights were long, with the towns of mandatory blackouts.
The barkeep's daughter tried to plant laser transmitters for
detonating explosives.
She got caught.
Kara, congrats!
Congrats!
Oh!
Hello, 13.
It was Yellow 13.
He knew she was responsible for planning the bomb on their
runway as well.
Rutt roll.
The face of the enemy, whom he hated, belonged to someone
close to him.
Get out of our town, you fascist pig.
Those were the words from my mouth.
I've never seen his face twist so painfully oh do you hate
us that much we couldn't shake or nod our heads in reply
yeah because I mean he has hated this guy since the
beginning before he said go and released us the next day
there was no change in his attitude as usual he made his
requests to the squadron crew chief the poor fuel quality is
affecting thrust as soon as the allied forces drew near the
resistance would end the blackouts over the city
favorite cutscene for four yellow 13 seems like a
complicated character i think maybe
very anti-war for a game about war metal gear so funny I
keep playing these war games that are very the messaging is
so anti-war no some some scenes like people don't like war
it's not sans-salvation was a neutral city at the start of
the war until the illusions occupied it we will not funny
how that happens the heaviest resistance will come from the
Tank Battalion near Route 7.
Tank Battalion.
And the anti-tank helicopters near the new city government
complex.
In addition, you must defend our allies from any airstrikes
that may originate from the airport behind you.
Okay.
The resistance fighters will end the Black Arrow City.
War belongs in fiction.
Suppress all enemy resistance and help with the new city.
Plains are so cool.
But war is not cool.
Why couldn't, why can't we handle everything in like a VR?
Boy, the best mission!
Is that sarcasm?
Please be...
Hopefully it's the best mission, right?
Like riding!
Welcome to Ace Combat.
Plains rule!
Ward rules!
Yeah!
Not sarcasm, it's a good mission.
Oh!
Wait, yes, sarcasm.
It's a fun mission.
We have lots of ground.
It's not a score mission, is it?
It's just a defense?
So we probably would want something kind of a little
well-rounded.
Good luck, man.
Thank you!
Oh, it is score mission.
Okay, just kidding.
Mixed air and ground.
Got it.
Anti-air will help.
Maybe the F-15 one.
Probably.
Score mission, but not bad.
Let's go sell our guy.
Goodbye.
Did we unlock anything new, I wonder?
Oh!
Yes, we did.
This guy.
I think this is probably better.
I have 15 my goat.
Uh...
The air targets are a little juicy for points, so it doesn't
hurt to be a little flexible with the empty air.
Okay, good to know.
Let's see.
Air to air.
No.
We'll get this one.
Yippee!
Alright.
I know I just saved, but...
You know me.
Mission 15!
Let's see.
I bought these, but let's see what's... I can't have it.
Air to ground.
We'll get this.
We'll still use the air to arrow.
If we get good points, if we're in the air.
Score at least 2,000 points within the time limit and
continue to destroy enemy forces.
Okay.
Strike Eagle is my favorite point.
Mobius 1, Sky Eye here.
The resistance just ended the blackout.
Commence operations.
Sweep out all enemy forces in old town, new city, and the
airport.
This one's close, right?
I'm still no joy.
Still no joy.
Don't be predictable in heading around the tube when they
close in.
Uh, whoops, I'm going too far now.
Oh, there they are.
There's some right there.
Uh, yeah.
Clear to engage.
Oh.
Mobius 1.
Engage.
I'm engaging.
Uh, I probably should have switched to this.
Oh, I got him.
I
have a bandit on my tail.
Oh, I guess I do.
Woo!
Oh, there's some stuff over here.
Oh, shoot.
Where'd they go?
Over here.
The music is so good.
Launcher.
Take it out.
Yippee!
Woo!
Oh, I can get that guy.
Yeah, I see him too.
Yellow.
Maybe.
Maybe?
Oh, I hit him?
Still got him?
Oh no, a yellow.
Yeah?
Oh shoot, dang it.
Missile shot trashed.
Yeah, I know, sorry.
There you go.
Yeah!
Goodbye yellow.
Got a yellow.
Now where did that...
There it is.
We want that one.
This launcher here.
Nice.
I'll go in from 12 o'clock.
Enemy vehicle destroyed.
Yeah.
I shot down a yellow.
I did it.
I see them.
Oh, I'll take that out.
Sure.
That's not what I wanted to get.
Um...
No, you're not.
I don't know what I'm locked on, actually, so I'm confused
where I'm going.
I'm just following the arrow.
But I... There we go.
Okay.
There should be...
Some...
Yellow's in here.
Can't... There we go.
They ate guns destroyed.
What is shooting at me, though?
Is it a person?
Let's get out of here.
We'll go over this way.
Sam's.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
I didn't see any guys.
My friend.
My friend is down there.
The music is so...
Like, Emoi.
Old Town.
Vector 070.
Find some more.
Oh, there's some more.
Wait.
They confirmed at Vector 1.00.
Oh, wait.
Wait, are you a yellow?
A yellow!
Locked on.
Oh, shoot.
I lost him.
Oh, so close.
I'm counting on you.
Maybe?
I think I got him.
Yeah!
What's my call sign?
The minkster.
Wait.
I'm not even halfway though.
This is pretty bad.
Nope, that's not gonna hit at all.
Just go after.
That altitude
is crazy.
Oh shoot.
Oh!
Whoa!
You're shooting at me!
Missile!
Where'd he go?
It's like right on my ass.
Holy cow.
I'm stalling, I'm stalling.
Come on, come on.
Missa!
Am
I wasting too much time on these guys, I wonder?
Ah, but I got him.
Ah!
I don't know if I'll have time to...
It's an A-Tud!
Those guys are so fast and speedy and they zip around and I
can't...
I can't get them.
Ever.
Dang, I actually missed him.
I think I got him this time.
There we go.
The A-Tud fast?
Oh yeah.
Don't you know?
That's like the new meta.
I'm like locked on.
Come here, guys.
Come here.
Yeah.
I'm still not even...
I'm just over a little half.
This is kind of bad.
Maybe ground stuff would be better then.
Oh, yes.
Missed.
Target rich areas, you can make up for it fast with a single
strife.
Let's uh, I don't know.
There's like a couple up there.
A orange is, wait, there's some orange over here as well,
right?
Right over this way.
The launchers and stuff.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
All right, now.
Mobius 1, Fox 2.
Enemy vehicle destroyed.
Oh my gosh.
Get off my booty.
Oops, I'm going.
Which way am I going now?
Wait.
Which way is it?
Hold on.
They gotta be positioned.
Oh, I have all the...
Ah!
I don't think I'll have enough time.
Less than a minute.
I'm gonna switch to my other...
San Propheta Airport at Vector 3008 miles.
Fun attempt, though.
Bandit confirmed at Vector 260.
Box 2.
Oh,
I got somebody!
Everything in here is like...
Box one, box one.
Bandit closing at six.
Ah!
Ugh.
Hmm.
This is a points buffet.
Yeah.
Multi-ground, target ground would get more points overall.
I wonder.
It was fun getting like the...
What's it called?
The yellow peep, the yellow, the yellow squad.
But...
Did you forget how to go third person?
No.
RM1 with multi-ground is pretty good.
Good.
Maybe we...
Phil sent this earlier.
Has a...
Wait.
Has an on-off migrant asked for a feel-better wiggle.
Here's the stream muted.
No!
Fail!
Feel better wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
Feel better wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle,
wiggle, wiggle.
Feel better wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
I like how you're consoling Sky Eye like a mother after you
get grumpy.
Not that you missed a missile shot.
Missile shot trash.
I know, I'm sorry.
I don't want to do ground.
I want to just shoot plane in the sky.
But I fear that I should get a multi-target homing something
or other.
You know...
Do ground first, then air.
That's what I was thinking too.
Like, uh...
The F-15 that we have is an all-rounder, but...
Oh, whoops.
Our weapon...
We have the air to air, which I...
That's my fault.
I didn't use it until like...
You know.
But the other one was like the cluster bomb.
Raphael is pretty solid for the ground.
Maybe we should do that one then.
Oh wait.
Let me sell this guy.
F-15's cluster bombs are really good.
They are?
Really?
Wait, they are?
I thought I was told that they weren't good.
I'll try it.
It doesn't hurt to try it.
Spread bomb.
They have huge AoE.
It's a matter of...
Okay, so...
It's a matter of, I usually don't know how to...
When to drop them, rather.
You know what I mean?
Maybe we go up to that top area first, the one that had
the...
I mean, we still have our regular missiles as well.
The resistance just ended the blackout.
But this area up here, like, had mega...
Sweep out all enemy forces in Old Town, New City, and the
airport.
Wait.
Actually, hold on, there was like this, these launchers over
here.
Oh yeah, there's like a bunch right here.
Not you.
Oh, wait, am I above it?
Yes.
Oh,
I launched it and I don't know.
if I did anything.
Oh, I destroyed something.
It is now 12.05 a.m.
Use your
central...
Enemy vehicle destroyed.
Alright.
Took those out real quick.
Since it was nice and close, bye.
Go right now.
Here, I can do it here, too.
Maybe?
Who?
Me?
Who's here?
Okay, oh, uh...
Oh!
Did I blow up anything?
I don't quite...
I don't quite know how...
That's an issue, as I...
You know, people be like, try these things, but I don't
quite know how to use them.
You know what I mean?
So it's tough for me.
Omega 11.
Omega 1, engage.
Enemy vehicle destroyed.
That's why we try.
The circle is where it lands.
Oh, I'm going the wrong way.
Mandy confirmed at Victor 020.
What the heck?
Who's on my booty?
Alright, circle.
Did I get it?
How many did I get?
I'm trying to get like
Fox 2, Fox 2 Where is my Okay, hold on, I'm getting a little
lost in the sauce here Okay, hold on I gotta take it out
Alright From 200 to 660 Oh damn, okay, alright, alright
Let's slow down a little bit And get a bunch of stuff in
here.
Okay, I see.
I see the...
Okay, okay.
And bombs away!
Bombs away!
Holy!
I got to a thousand points!
Holy cow!
That was craziness!
Over here?
Alja, don't do that.
Please say yes to that.
Destroyed that.
Destroyed!
Alright, let's take out some of...
Alright, hold on.
Please.
Go away.
Annoying Sam.
Sam kept ruining my plans.
Yeah, that's some AOE for real.
Oh, please.
The hangar.
Yes.
Ouch.
Obious one.
Sky eye here.
The airport has been neutralized.
Flow to support other areas.
Come on, come on.
Come on.
Oh, that was not good.
Dang it.
Damn it.
The 30th Obious one.
She went right over me, crazy.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I took that.
Were there any other places that had...
Actually...
I wonder if I can grab them.
No!
Alright, hold on.
We're just gonna...
We're gonna go to the next cluster of stuff.
I think.
Hold on, I'm just getting lost.
Okay, north, south.
I gotta go to... Sorry, guys.
Oh, that...
We'll go south.
Okay, see ya.
We're going south.
We have not gone over this way yet.
Still four minutes.
The 500 left.
We're just going to ignore those guys for now.
Yeah, later.
Later, nerds.
I got my...
Big...
Big guy.
Alright, let's...
Let's see.
I don't think I did.
Did I get anything?
No,
we're...
Okay, all I see is friend, friend, friend, friend, friend.
Like right there?
Like this group?
I mean, I don't...
Okay!
Did I get any of you?
Uh...
I don't think I did.
Oh!
Oh, yes we did!
We got a couple.
Now it's my six o'clock Omega five.
But still, I need more.
This guy's worth 60 points.
Now 400 points left.
Come on, come on.
I think
we got him.
Yeah!
But now I have a yellow on...
Oh, he's worth 150 points!
Yeah, he's really on my nose.
Come on, we're gonna go...
Ah!
They're super zippy.
Oh, I'm stalling!
Shoot, I had him.
Please!
Yes!
Yeah, we got that guy, okay.
The east side of the highway is wide.
Check behind you.
I see them.
Hmm?
Where is he?
Oh, it's an A-10.
Yeah.
I only have less than a minute though.
Ooh.
Is it another A-10?
Yeah.
Oh.
I only have less than a minute though.
Is it another A-10?
Oh.
Tango 3 here We're fighting on Route 7 near the arch Radar
lock
There we go, maybe Yes Okay, I think we need to go destroy
like some Oh my gosh, oh my gosh Wait Okay, all right, maybe
we could do this Maybe we could do this Maybe we could do
this With some crazy Come on, come on, come on, come on Come
on, come on A little bit more Explode, explode, explode
Another, another, another Please please please please please
destroy destroy destroy please oh no oh I shot them I did I
shot them you can see there's only three left oh they're so
slow the missiles are so slow
No!
Ah!
Mobius I here.
The resistance just ended the blackout.
Commence operations.
Sweep out all enemy forces in Old Town, New City, and the
Air Force.
I didn't hesitate.
They were just slow.
Don't be hasty.
He just said, don't be hasty.
Which is it?
I'm getting mixed messages here.
You guys are saying, don't hesitate.
And this guy's saying, don't be hasty.
Now, I'm just confused.
I'm a confused little newbie pilot.
All right.
Various explosions every
time.
Come on, it's one.
Mobius one, engage.
Woo!
Oops, my bad.
Mobius 1 crash.
No, that guy didn't.
I rewrite history.
Mobius 1, Sky Eye here.
I didn't notice the buildings.
My bad.
Commence operations.
Oh, yeah.
Hold on.
All enemy forces in Old Town, New City, and the airport.
Watch me earn my ace wings today.
Aw, my friends are so cute.
No, not you.
Not you.
That guy, yeah.
How big of an AOE is it even?
Like, if I do this...
Higher up is bigger AOE, but more travel.
I feel like I didn't get that many, though.
Let's get out of here.
Yep.
All right, I'm gonna leave it to you, friends.
I need you guys to handle, handle it.
Uh...
I need you guys to handle it and I go do stuff, okay?
Down on the ground.
Like that.
They paid, they paid, they paid, they paid!
Can I get some more things down here though?
Oh wait, let's do this.
Did I destroy anything else?
That's what I'm wondering.
Yo, yo, yo, yo.
I don't think I got anything.
I'm so confused.
Because I was...
I feel like I'm...
It works sometimes.
And I don't quite get it.
Like I'm shooting within the...
The circle, you know?
But...
Oh, wait, where am I?
Not here.
Not there yet.
Like, I think that...
That shot...
The music is so good.
Holy cow.
Okay, so that definitely launched.
Um...
Okay, there's still more though.
Oh, okay, the hanger.
Hold on.
Ouch!
Oh!
Okay, we gotta circle back around.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
no, I messed up.
All right.
Come here.
Is that a revenge fighter?
Missile!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah, but like, why is my other.
missile not doing anything is my question is am i
overestimating the aoe on it i don't know like is it
i'm so confused i'm too low
we're too low for it to have speed okay well there's only
one left at this point now anyway so this is why it's hard
to learn new things wait I'm not supposed to be on you no no
wait no stop stop targeting target though I'm starting to
get lost and the sauce.
Wow, this area is almost cleared.
Let's go.
Okay.
Um, then I'm gonna go to south uh, west.
No.
East street.
You got this.
Thank you!
I appreciate it.
Yeah, let's get out of here.
Let's go focus on another area.
try and get higher.
Bomb physics in this game is kind of weird so it's hard to
drop the bomb sometimes.
Thanks, Nahn, I appreciate it.
Clusters and UGB fall, they don't fly.
Yeah, yeah, that's what people were mentioning.
It's just...
I'm not used to it.
So it's not something that I'm like, you know what I mean?
Oops, oh, I forgot to grab the other one.
I forgot to grab the other one.
the other one.
Yui, New turn.
Alright.
Let's get up.
Up up up, up up up up up up.
Okay.
There's a group.
There's a big old cluster.
Bamsoom!
Yay!
And, uh, erm, uh,
oh, we got, like, a hundred something there.
But, like, there's no other good clusters.
Ah!
Leave me alone, I'm searching!
At least we can take out that, Sam.
I think.
I think I did.
Take a two at 1.650 feet of heart.
enemy radar spike um okay we gotta go back up up up up up up
up up up up up up okay i'm getting a little lost in the
saucer okay all right let's turn around
yeah i just took out that like a10 just okay here we go Now
I can see again.
There we go.
Over there.
Alright.
Maybe there.
I can grab.
And maybe...
There.
Okay.
And then...
Uh...
Ooh.
Ooh, that was close.
I'm just dropping.
I destroyed something.
I think I gotta go in now with my like missile missile.
I think it's time to go in and use missile missiles.
Ah!
I hate timed missions so much.
I hate these stupid score missions.
Ah!
I didn't notice the time at all.
Give me a second.
I'm going to go get some water.
Okay, I'm back.
Sorry about that.
I'll show my party.
Okay.
Let's retry.
Mobius 1, Sky Eye here.
The resistance just ended the blackout.
Commence operations.
Sweep out all enemy forces in Old Town, New City, and the
airport.
Okay.
Let's try and keep my altitude relatively high.
Maybe we can knock out more of these at once.
Yeah, we're close.
I just gotta...
Just gotta do it.
I'll assist with reentry.
I'll take this one.
And we'll do another one for a safe measure.
Hoi!
But altitude high.
And hoi!
And...
Oh!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
And uh...
There was another one.
Wait.
Hold on.
Let me just circle around.
What, I mean?
Let me get that orange plate.
Are helicopters not yellows?
Oh, they are?
I don't think I hit anything that I was trying to hit.
I can't...
I don't think I hit anything.
Nothing for.
That's so funny.
I think it's some hits.
I'm only at 150, though.
Where's another cluster we can do?
AA guns destroyed.
Wait, over.
Oh, wait.
Where'd it go?
Ah.
I see it on the screen, but I don't see it myself.
Hold on.
I think they're probably a bunch of Sam's yelling at me.
Okay.
Thank you.
My tolerance this week is a little lower for for things like
this, so I apologize in advance.
Can I just get this guy?
You're... you're annoying me.
Just because I've been so busy.
So I'm... Oh my gosh, this guy is...
This guy is on me.
Miss, miss, miss, miss!
Come
on.
Where is it?
Oh, I was on the missile!
No!
Ah!
I didn't!
I...
I clicked select and it did not register!
Okay, where are these guys?
Ouch.
I see the national broadcast building.
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh.
I already want to restart.
I estimate there are quite another of them.
Take destroyed.
Imagine the rest of your team watching that.
Mobius, are you okay?
Guys, I'm not having such a good day.
Yeah, maybe we should change planes.
It's been a couple times I've tried this one, and I've been
close, but...
This is the Rafale, right?
Right.
Please don't tell me how to play, thank you.
And especially don't send me money to tell me how to play,
because that makes me feel bad.
Oh, oh, this one.
Is this one?
Wait, this is the one that I didn't know how to use before.
I feel like this is the one...
I could try again.
But I feel like...
I feel like...
Um...
It has AoE?
Oh, it does!
I feel like I should get a multi-target thing.
What is a... What would be a multi-target?
That would be good.
Tax are all messing up.
Multi would be best.
Yeah.
4-8GM.
What plane has a...
Let's see.
What plane has a 4AGM?
If I could read.
A10 and F18.
I don't want the A10.
I think it'll be too slow.
A little bit.
Am
I crazy?
F16 has them?
White text on lens playback.
I know it drives me insane.
Actually driving me crazy.
Oh, here.
Okay.
Wait, where's that F-16?
Where are you?
I can try it.
Purchase.
The light blue.
Oh, oops.
Wrong one.
That's 16.
Oh, here we go.
Yes!
Voices.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's retry.
Hopefully this time...
Maybe we'll be okay.
Maybe.
We'll see.
Bada bing, bada boom, baby.
I need your encouragement!
Aibus!
Don't you hear me?
Commence operations.
Sweep out all enemy forces in old town, new city, and the
airport.
Okay.
Wait, so these are...
No.
These are helicopters?
Are these...
Oh, that is a helicopter!
It's only 8... Oh, it's 80 points.
I mean, 80 is better than...
Nothing.
Various explosions and reports from the fighters can be
heard.
What?
Well, grab the other one.
one then.
I had no idea.
Thanks for letting me know.
We'll
have third one takes, though.
Oh, nope.
This one.
Absolutely.
I think I missed one.
Wait.
Did I?
Yeah.
Shoot.
I think it was before it like locked on.
I accidentally went.
Okay.
Let's see.
My friend!
I wonder if it would be worse, like...
Splash one, Splash one!
Splash one!
Nagato, Nagato!
Sam destroyed!
I accidentally just launched one.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm Ian and I'm yawned?
Okay, thank you.
These two also, please?
Oh, there we go.
I don't know if that actually...
You're doing it, Vito!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Pull up!
Okay.
Alright.
We're getting a little crazy in this here.
Okay.
I think I will just go somewhere else.
Let's get out of here.
Let's go somewhere else.
I think we've kind of... We haven't cleared the... Wait!
Before I do that.
Hold on, I'm gonna go.
We have time, maybe, if I go straight there and straight
back.
We're just gonna run.
We're gonna run and restock our other ATMs.
Because we're really close to the start.
Return to base.
Yeah, yeah.
All right.
Take off.
Yeah.
That'll go.
no matter how difficult thank you all right now we just go
northeast ish a little a little ish all right all right all
the way up there and we'll just
again we're almost halfway there oh i was it's funny because
i think last stream i was complaining, I was like, man, why
can't they give us a less score?
Or, like, make the things worth more?
And here I am.
Okay, now you only, instead of 3,000, you have to get 2,000.
But the time is so limited.
Bandit confirmed in vector 030.
Oh, wow, there's so much stuff here.
Come on.
Let's start locking in.
Locking in.
Oh, I bought the wrong I think we
need to back on new stuff now.
No!
Ooh, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Enemy facility destroyed.
All right, more orange to eat.
I love orange.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Check six.
Go.
Bandit.
closing at six so until last oh i did it no way no staking
way no way what that's crazy it was so fast
what surface target destroyed what What?
It was so fast.
I think I got him.
No, I lied.
Up, up, up, up.
I think I got him.
I did not.
Maybe now.
I think I did.
Yeah!
Is this a yellow?
Imagine if I got him first shot.
That would be crazy.
Yellow squadron.
I want at least one!
I'm going to eat one of you guys.
Oh, so close.
Come on.
Oh, please.
Missing shot trashed.
Trashed.
I was shooting at him instead.
They're so...
He's like they're playing with me.
Every time.
Every time I turn around, he's already flying past me.
There.
Over there.
Right.
Like...
There's three of us on him.
We can't get him.
That's crazy.
Oh!
Yee-hoo!
Wait, is this area?
It's like nearly clean.
That's crazy.
Yay!
Nice shot, thank you!
Wait.
Another yellow.
12 o'clock.
Maybe we could go after this guy first.
How many did you shoot down?
So many?
Don't even worry about it.
Don't even... I've shot down like a million of them.
Oh, I don't... I'm not gonna get it.
Dang it!
Yeah, I know.
Oh, you can get this guy too.
I'm thirsty for blood now.
I'm thirsty.
Oh!
My friend did that!
Check behind you.
She's clean.
Oh, I'm stalling.
She's cleaning house.
Maybe?
Oh!
Yeah!
It feels so good!
Oh, we're just gonna clean this area.
Where did that guy go?
No, no.
This guy over here.
Minto in her victory lap.
Oh.
Multiple TU-160s are inbound to new city from the Northwest.
Drive them back immediately.
Damn, fascists!
They're gonna level the city!
Northwest?
Oh, wrong way.
I thought you meant weist!
Oh, that's not Northwest, that's just... that's just West.
Wait, I'm going like Southwest.
A single fighter has yet to be sighted, but generally it's
getting hurt.
They're fast bombers.
They're like more southwest than northwest.
Holy, they're fast.
Like altitude.
Watch out.
We're almost there?
Where are they?
Yes.
Oh, they're above me.
Alright.
Oh, this is gonna be...
Okay, let's let him go back past me.
Maybe?
This is bad.
We're surrounded.
Fox 2.
Maybe I got him?
Yes, uh...
Black Jack!
You're speaking my language.
Come on, come on.
Wait, I had him.
Is he just that fast?
Come on!
Oh my god, they're really fast.
Holy, this guy is zooming.
12 o'clock.
Ah!
I'm like, oh my god, I think I just passed another guy and
just trying to catch up to this dude.
I don't think I'm even gonna get him.
Oh shoot, I did.
Holy.
Trying to turn around.
Where are you?
Are my friends doing their work at all?
Oh my gosh, I cannot catch up with these dudes.
My finger is hurting.
Come on!
Give me tone!
Yes.
Come on!
I think I got him.
There they go, flying above us.
These planes are only visible when they explode.
Oh my gosh, he's already...
He's already past me.
This is coming to you live.
There he is.
Radio failure!
Oh gosh.
I need my team to like...
Oh my god.
I'm worried we're not gonna make it.
Please, then lock on and shoot!
If you have a lock on, then shoot!
I'm taking these guys out single-handed Ah, that was so
close Look how close we are to the line Gas, gas,
gas, gas, gas The Arushan officer in charge of censoring
Broxie Has evacuated as well Yes, yes, yes.
Now we can shout victory is ours.
Victory is ours!
Gregory Wolski reporting for community broadcast.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Ah, we did it.
The victory was not only a strategic one, but a symbolic one
as well.
Though it is still dark outside, cheering can be heard
throughout the city.
Wow.
Yeah, F-16.
Lovely.
I got a rank right here.
Oh, I may have cursed this mission.
Rest in question.
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you.
Yeah, F-16 may be my baby.
Wow, everybody's cheering.
Hip-hip pariah and throwing up their babies.
Singing.
But then fighting through mixture victories hours!
The mixture lives!
The mixture defeats!
During the night raids, the AA gunners had strafed the town
in an attempt to shoot down low-flying aircraft.
The town militia now rounded up these gunners.
They retreated as well, and now their quarters stood empty.
They... Oh!
After what seemed like a long absence, Allied aircraft
soared overhead.
I wondered if the fateful enemy ace, the one that Yellow 13
longed to meet, is on alert.
What would happen if they ever came face to face?
I fell in with the rounded erosions and followed after the
squadron.
Ah!
We did it.
that's three missions left 16 17 and 18 they would smooches
maybe whiskey corridor purely ground-based for the next one
whiskey corridor is a narrow strip of land between Lambert
and Amber mountains the enemy has deployed a large tank
force at the end of the corridor as it final line of defense
despite being outnumbered our allies must face this enemy
contingent and head-on this mission sucks our projected
casualty rate is extremely high oh wow we need a miracle in
air support to win this battle okay annihilate enemy ground
forces and provide direct close air support through our
troops 113 ground.
What's this?
113 targets on the ground.
But is this the last ground mission?
This mission is insanely tedious.
Oh, I wish I could skip it.
Not exactly.
Second to last.
Okay.
Oh.
This one's new.
But not good at ground.
Let me do it.
I want to do ground assault.
Okay.
I pass my controller to you.
If I had like a big brother and I was playing this game and
he was watching me play and he's just like okay next mission
I would get I would do that I would give them I would give
my controller to him and be like can you do this one for me
I'd be like can you I don't want to do this one can you do
it for me please mission update pass the controller yeah you
know he's just wait always the wait learn to Bob later in
the future game they're much easier especially in Ace Combat
7 yeah yeah what should i do then what should i what should
i what do you guys what you think i should go a tug i just
worry oops i just spat all over myself i would have helped
so bad the f16 again keep using the ajms honestly they're so
great aren't they but i feel like is the map super big
because if it is it's difficult to get, like, around is my
only thing.
I think you got good synergy with F-16.
I agree, honestly.
Let's just...
Let's try it.
We can try the mission and always change later.
Let's just try it with my F-16.
3,500 points.
The thing I also hate about these missions is, especially if
timeout usually like let's see how long this one is 20
minutes that's a waste of 20 minutes you know what I mean
this is primarily a ground battle so our duty is to provide
close air support all right we're gonna go immediately over
to these ones that are close to the lines and and with with
oranges 20 minutes it's such a waste of time
God, I hate playing games.
Whiskey Corridor sounds like a good time.
Happy for you.
Grab these two?
Oh, these weren't.
I thought it was orange.
Take destroyed.
Friend,
friend.
Hello, friend?
Come on.
Enemy facility destroyed.
Tank destroyed.
Give me a look.
What
did I just get?
I'm trying to get the orange here.
Tank destroyed!
Yeah?
I think...
No, that's not it either.
Where is...
Oh, I went too far.
They
like...
Can I get the other two?
Oh, I only have the one left.
Well, that sucks.
Ay,
ay...
I don't want to go north.
We're going south?
Zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom, zum,
zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom,
zoom, zoom…
The music is so cool.
Oh my gosh.
It's making me have noise!
Oh!
I don't want to... Okay, back to music.
Vendor confirmed at vector 340.
Really good soundtrack.
Yeah.
I'll take it from here.
That guy's just sitting there.
I'm leaving.
Let's see you.
Let's see you, suckers.
Oh, wait.
I'm not going the right way at all.
Oops.
We're fine.
Now we're headed the right way.
Hello, friends!
Uh...
Enemy
facility destroyed.
Nice.
I can't get out of here!
There's still oranges!
I'm already feeling like I'm too slow though.
I'm already feeling like I'm too slow.
Where is it?
It's...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
I'm not okay.
I hear you!
Wait, where's my pointer?
I feel like I'm not zippy.
I feel like I'm not zippy enough.
Enemy facility destroyed.
Check six.
These two missiles.
Shit, you asshole.
Am I supposed to get a lock on it?
You don't stop bothering me!
Okay, let's get out of here.
Let's get out of here.
One
reason I don't like flying in third-person mode is because
they take away your And so I actually don't know where I'm
going.
Friendly's went, holy heck, it's Mobius 1.
I even have a chat.
We're not even halfway.
And I have only three.
Hold on.
One second.
I'm going to move.
So you guys can see as well.
I'll, like, do this.
Because it's kind of tough to...
There we go.
Okay.
Should have done that.
I don't
know where to go.
Up here?
It's okay.
These ones usually take a
couple...
Take Destroyed.
I don't think I can do this though without...
I mean, like, it might be able to like...
With my gun.
But I'm scared.
Come on, go.
Take out that Sam because he's annoying me.
Sam destroyed.
Yeah, thank you.
Take destroyed.
But I'm still not even halfway there.
HQ!
How much is that worth?
Enemy facility destroyed.
Missed?
What did I miss?
What do you mean I missed?
I can't stand playing.
Good third person.
I think it's this guy, the one that I'm targeted on.
Where are you?
Oh my gosh.
No, you're just a gun.
Where's, is there, there's got to be a Sam around here.
No?
That's a tank.
What are you guys?
Wait, can I...
Ah!
See, this is why I never use my gun!
It doesn't do shit!
Why are bullets so useless?
What is shooting at me?
I can't see his damn Sam anywhere!
Or nothing!
Where's the Sam?
It's just non-stop warning.
It's so annoying.
Oh my god.
Shut up.
You're annoying me.
Sam right side.
I don't believe you.
Wait, is it there?
Is that it?
No, that's a tank.
I thought the Sam...
I thought Sam...
Or, like, I thought the guns and stuff are supposed to be...
Oh, well, that's a gun.
Maybe not.
Where are you?
I found it!
Yes.
You, you, you.
I'm gonna go refill.
How about, how, let's see.
We have eight minutes.
Let's see how long it takes us to get.
And then there's that line down there of like, I think it's
a bunch of tanks.
Let's see how long it takes us to get from the tippy tippy
top all the way to the bottom.
We can still, I'll try and still grab it while I'm on my way
down, I guess.
Music is so good.
If only I wasn't so...
I mean, I feel stressed.
I feel...
A ghost in battle.
Tank destroyed.
Mobius 1, Fox 2.
Missile shot trashed.
What?
What do you mean?
How?
How did I miss?
He's right there.
Oh, it's a Sam.
I got you.
Okay, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Six and a half, and we're, I still need over a thousand
points.
Don't shoot me, I'm baiting.
to the other areas and maybe bombs away i'm scared bgm so
hard all right return to wish
noobius ones you are cleared for take thank you all right
that seems right maybe
i there's two friends there they can Take care of it.
They're just kind of chilling in the air, actually.
Of me?
Leave me alone.
Can't shake it.
He's not even on you.
Old anchor point city.
When vectors 0, 3, 0, 8 miles.
All right.
Is this...
I'm
sorry.
Please.
where is everything hello everything blends into the ground
it's so hard to tell all right here we go
you're messing with the minx story wait uh i can't see
anything oh here what
is this oh it's a tank sure all right uh Turn upwards?
Turn to...
I only have three minutes!
Eke!
Stress, stress, stress.
Come on,
give me tone, give me tone, give me tone, give me tone.
Let's get this guy before he becomes a huge pain in my butt.
Enemy vehicle destroyed.
Oh shoot, I lost, okay.
Two minutes, two minutes.
Yeah, shush, shush, shush, shush, shush.
Okay, it's so quiet all of a sudden.
Why is it so quiet all of a sudden?
Please, the other one, please!
There we go.
Enemy vehicle destroyed.
Obvious one, box two.
Oh, so close, so close.
Enemy vehicle destroyed.
Just a little bit more.
Anything else around here?
Yes.
Alright, I think we are just about it.
And with a little time to spare!
Yahoo!
Mobius 1, box 2.
Enemy vehicle destroyed.
Yay!
Yippee!
Holy cow.
All right, we can relax for a little bit.
Oh, uh, that's right.
We could go up here, I guess.
I don't know.
I'm bored?
I'm not bored.
Oh, holy cow!
Oh, let's just go up here, I guess.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
This reminds me of, like, a Final Fantasy Eris theme.
Step 16 is baby.
I am baby piloting it, too.
Do, do, do, do.
Oh, seven, six, five, four.
Beep, beep.
Feels good.
Sky Eye here.
The enemy is in retreat.
Ah!
The troops are advancing.
Feels good.
Mission complete.
All aircraft are TB.
Oh.
RTB.
Oh, you do it for me.
Yahoo!
The enemy abandoned its defensive line, and the road to
their path lies open.
Yes!
So many points!
And we did it!
See?
See, rank is okay.
First try, great pilot, piloting minster.
Thank you.
Save.
Save the game.
Whiskey corridor.
See Jafar Bonte.
Third person was meant to design tracking camera by holding
the triangle.
Not the best for free camera unlike first person.
I like, I don't know, I feel like I can maneuver much more
easily in third person, or in first person, which makes
sense.
I was here in Ace Combat 7?
I don't remember.
I'll try to remember now.
The enemy GHQ is located beneath a landfill on the coast of
their capital, Farbante,
which will enter via the Silver Bridge to the southeast and
the flooded city to the south.
We give her the zip for time!
You must attack all the enemy forces and support our troops.
Enemy tank forces are also closing in from the north.
Destroy Johnson Memorial Bridge to stop them from joining
the war.
It's a memorial bridge!
Got it.
But the megalith!
I forgot about this thing!
I forgot about the megalith!
Uh oh.
So is this the, uh, another ground?
This, the, another point?
I'm surprised that it's not telling me the target is the
bridge.
I already see what you guys are telling me to do.
I'm not gonna sell you just yet.
Sell this one.
Oh, I'm such a silly goose.
Oh, yes, you.
I like how people are like, buy this plane when I don't even
know that it was unlocked.
They're like, buy the plane!
Wait, everyone's telling me to buy the F-22?
I don't even have it.
Whoa, wait, this one's crazy, though.
Unverable F-15.
Wow.
Where?
It's before the F-15.
This is the Su-37.
SU.
I don't think 37 is a 22.
Before 37.
36.
Why didn't you say so?
Wait, which one would be better though?
This one seems more...
Actually, maybe this one.
Exceptional fighter.
Superior maneuverability.
Payload stealth.
Whoa, wait a second.
Holy cow, the number of missiles this thing can take.
Like it can hold.
Wow!
Whoa!
Okay, I'll buy it.
But not because you asked me to do it.
Because I wanted to.
But what does it have?
Wait.
Was this one good?
I can't remember.
A piggy jerry blade.
It does have a guided bomb.
It's okay.
Wait, hold on.
Oh,
wait.
But it's air to air.
It's amazing.
Amazing air to air.
Well, it did say there's a score at least 2,100 points
within the time limit and continue to destroy enemy.
2,100 points.
Okay.
Oh, everything's like kind of all close together, which is
nice.
Remember, survival is paramount.
Good luck to you all.
Thank you.
Love is one.
An end to the war would be a nice birthday gift as well.
Wait, it's still your birthday?
Don't lie.
I am so stupid.
You guys, why did I...
Why did I wait?
Sorry, I got... I'm a little lost in the sauce right now.
Dang, this thing flies smooth.
I don't even know if I should be going after these guys, but
points are points, right?
So, maybe.
It's fine.
Okay.
Like you're awesome in F-22?
We're 20.
It's not working.
I can't.
Get our lock.
Mobius 1, Fox 2.
No.
Silver Bridge.
Head Vector 010.
Four miles.
We got 10 minutes.
Watch.
I guess we should go blow up stuff.
You're coming in.
Silver Bridge.
Oh.
They were already...
They were already way up on me.
Oh,
whoops.
Can I like just start gunning and down?
Let's get the sound.
Oh, that's a bridge.
Dang, I didn't get the ship!
Oh, I'll get him.
Is the ship worth a lot?
Was there any orange?
Or am I crazy?
I don't see it.
I do, but I don't.
Oh wait, there it is.
Yeah.
You...
Oh, okay.
Not the bridge!
Oh, that's a tank.
Wait.
Yes?
That's the bridge?
Is that the bridge?
There's actually several of them.
Can we?
Can we be specific, please?
Which bridge are we talking about?
Actually.
There's other stuff over here.
It's orange.
That said the bridge!
I got it.
We're fine.
Everything's good.
I want to get more...
Okay, it's a submarine.
Alright.
Oh, there it is.
I didn't even get that guy.
Did I get it?
I don't think so.
I don't think I can reach that.
Oh shoot, it's stuck in the buildings!
How are you supposed to get that?
Yeah, that's a really hard job.
Maybe in here?
Yeah, baby.
Mobius alive.
No pressure on me, sure.
Wait, is that it been?
Miss?
How am I supposed to get this thing?
Oh, I'm lost.
Wait.
Sorry.
There?
Oh, I did get it!
Let's go!
Yeah, baby.
Sam around here.
So annoying.
You're so annoying.
In my dreams, I hear it.
Enemy vehicle destroyed.
How much are you at 40 points?
Mobius 1, Fox 2.
Where's all the good stuff?
Take destroyed.
I guess...
Can I?
Uh...
Oh, so close.
Maybe?
Take.
I might hit... Oh, I got him!
Nice kill.
Thank you.
Um...
What is a... What's good to...
I feel like...
Good thing you're not on ace difficulty, that's all you'll
be hearing.
It's so annoying.
I feel like I...
I'm going so slow.
I mean, I still have five minutes, but it's just like...
Oh, you know.
Maybe I come in here and just start mowing them down, you
know?
Wait, get this guy?
There?
Oh, shit!
Holy!
I almost just ran into that!
Yeah, you guys are making me do all the work, for real.
Oh, dang it, that was a miss.
It's my fault.
That was completely my fault.
You saw the game over screen there.
Me too.
You're telling me.
Please,
there we go.
Yeah.
Battleship.
Are there more battleships?
That I could...
Any more battleships?
They feel like good...
Good, uh...
Fox 2.
There was only the one...
No, I took out another one earlier.
Oops, I accidentally just...
I think I accidentally just...
I think I accidentally just launched a...
Oh, Bissell on action.
We'll go over this way.
I don't know.
I'm kind of just like at a loss.
This is what to do to get more points, you know?
I guess we just got to mow down as much as we can.
It's three minutes left.
This is where the... what to do.
Bissell.
That itself is where I feel!
Almost there.
Yeah, 80 to go?
Okay, maybe...
Okay, this one's not so bad then.
I was worried for nothing, maybe.
Maybe.
Let's not get, uh...
I don't want to get too ahead of myself.
I don't know.
Obvious one, box two.
Take, destroy.
Okay!
Yippee!
I am almost out of missiles, aren't I?
Maybe I should turn around.
Easy work.
Yeah, okay.
I was worried for another...
I've got so paranoid now.
After everything else, you know?
This is your last moment with Yellow 13!
No, it's not.
Wait, should I go get more missiles then?
Debate, debate, debate!
Debate, debate!
Should I go get more missiles?
Yes?
Okay, just in case.
Okay.
I can't see- I- I fly it into the sun.
Okay, I think I'm going south.
I'm going south.
I can't see my HUD at all.
Okay, we're fine.
Maybe?
I'm just- I'm going down.
Actually, my altitude is dramatically drop-in.
Approaching point of return, maintain current course to
refute.
Thank you.
Mobius 1, perform landing check.
You are cleared to...
Okay.
Mobius 1, you are cleared...
It's okay guys, it's okay.
But try- try not to be so overzealous, you guys.
Don't- don't try not to say things that are going to happen
in a mission until they are happening.
No.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's also not gonna hit.
Wait, am I?
Oh!
I did not hear tank destroy.
I heard something else.
Oh.
Obious one.
Five aircraft are closing in at high speed.
It's the yellow squadron.
Looks like they've come to make a last stand for Eruja.
Let's settle this once and for all.
The choppers and to the others.
You can end this war.
Wait, it's all me?
All in on Minkee?
Oh, there they are.
Wait.
Approaching contact point.
Stay alert.
Holy cow.
Okay.
Oops, why did I accidentally launch my bed?
I don't even have toad.
That's fine.
We're gonna pass him.
Oh, shoot.
But my friends are also helping, right?
Oh, my God.
Holy cow!
I'm trying!
Box two, box two, missed.
They're just gonna keep going after me.
Oh shoot, no!
Oh my god, they're so fast, and I'm so fast, and
everything's happening at once.
Woohoo!
Okay, I see.
Maybe?
Oh my gosh.
I'm breaking!
Come on.
Oh, I got one!
I got one!
I got one, you guys!
Hold on.
Oh, dang.
Where is everybody?
Oh, these are my friends.
I hear you!
What do you think I'm doing?
You think I'm just ignoring you?
Oh my gosh, I have 15 minutes to beat them.
That's scary.
No!
Surely my other team can, my team can help though, right?
They're gonna be doing a good job.
I'm looking into the sun.
Missile!
It's not disappearing.
Watch me earn my ace wings today.
You better.
You better earn your ace wings today.
Holy cow.
This is exactly what I wanted, but it's also so terrifying.
Ah!
Can you see him pull up?
That was crazy!
He was right in front of me!
Oh!
I don't think so wait maybe oh yes okay we got another guy
Where are they are they above no they're below me but I
can't see them at all The Sun keeps getting my eye can we do
this at night
No.
Why not?
I can't see my HUD at all.
It's terrible actually.
Like I can't see where the...
Radar lock.
Fox 2.
Please, please.
Yes!
Okay.
Hard enemy radar spike.
Just two more.
Which one's yellow 13?
I think.
Fox 2.
Missed.
Hard enemy.
They are
pesky.
No you don't.
No!
Maybe,
maybe, maybe.
How did it move?
How?
Get on their tail.
Oh, I did not mean to do that.
That's okay, though.
Where is he?
I can't see him, please!
I can't see anything!
Oh, my God.
Break missile.
Where is...
Okay.
I'm like just chasing them.
It sucks.
They're chasing me and I'm chasing...
Oh my god.
Get off my ass, please.
They're like on top of each other, too.
Hold on.
How can I...
Yeah, they're chasing me.
It's so annoying.
So annoying.
Because I can't see them.
Oh, I hit him at least.
I gotta get on your tail.
Oh, shit.
I gotta watch my altitude, though.
Box
2?
Maybe?
Yeah!
Okay.
He's on my ass, he won't get off it.
Please.
I'm so high up.
I'm so high up right now.
I can't see him at all.
Where the hell is he?
This has to be him.
This has to be my guy
This has to be my guy Come on He won't get off me I can't
get on him Okay, actually I need like tips how how how?
My
god, yeah, she's pulling all the G's like good lord I'm my
special.
You're right.
Get more distance.
I can't even see what's what in anywhere, though.
But he's so...
He's always on me.
I can't even get a view of him.
Like, actually.
Like, I'm supposed to get away from him, but he's literally
on my butt the entire time.
You know?
Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, Wait, uh, please!
Let me see him.
Let me see him!
Ah!
Oh my god, he's obsessed with me.
Yeah, baby, we almost kissed!
Miss!
I love how someone was just like, This weapon can't miss!
This weapon can't miss!
It basically, as soon as you get him, locked on!
This weapon can't miss.
Place them.
This ship can't sink.
Holy shit!
Oh shit,
I'm almost dead.
Oh no, please don't make me do all this over again.
Please, please, please, please, please.
Please, please, please, please.
I don't think I can go back to base.
That's a kill.
Great job.
There are no aircraft remaining on radar.
I didn't need to head back to base.
I juked it.
I made him think that I was going back to base.
And I didn't because he thought I was going back to base.
And then I said, never mind!
Mobius 1 shot down the five aircraft that appeared.
Air superiority is ours.
You made it through alive, Mobius 1.
I did.
I said, I'm not going to go back to base.
He wasn't chasing after me like I thought he would, so...
Fearless ghost.
Thanks for nothing, Wingmen.
So true!
But they wanted us to have our moment.
It was kind of great.
There was a girl in the chopper.
Wee!
On September 19th at 1200 hours, the Erujian accepted the
ISAF terms for surrender.
Our victory came at an extremely high cost and casualties.
Got him with the switcheroo and gave him a smooch of death.
Yeah.
Extremely high cost and casualties.
Yeah, my sanity.
Holy cow.
Yellow 13's body vanished into the blue skies, never to
return to Earth.
Only a single handkerchief fluttered down from the sky where
he disappeared.
The handkerchief!
The faint scent of perfume.
Oh, he's sniffing it.
The barkeep's daughter and I had followed the squadron this
far.
Each of us had our own thoughts as we buried that
handkerchief.
It no longer mattered to me whether that was 13 or 4's
grave.
Their memories blurred together as one, and left the realm
of reality like a dream.
Sniffer, sniffer.
The terms of surrender were accepted that day, and the war
was over.
plans to play the other two yeah wait other two wait a plan
on playing five uh five zero six i want to play seven again
we'll see though oh seven yellow 13
mission 18.
Megalith.
Oh!
I think so often about the Ace Combat 7 mission where you're
like going up the sky elevator.
A group of young Eurasian officers have taken over Megalith,
the super weapon that was under development.
Megalith is a rocket launch facility that can shoot down
asteroid fragments in orbit.
the only way to destroy this highly dangerous and fortified
facility is to hit it from the inside follow the missile
port groups to find the three generators deep within the
facility destroy the generators to access this oh this is oh
my god wait this is also just like ace combat seven destroy
the giant missile in the central silo an infiltration unit
will secure your escape Maybe people not in planes should do
this.
Wait!
Maybe...
Enter this rat's nest with full confidence that the unit
will get you out again.
It's highly likely that this will be your final mission.
Remember, we need heroes after the war too.
Make it back in One Piece.
One Piece is real.
Dismissed.
Strap the heck in.
Oh, Lordy.
Why are we sending planes?
indoors.
Look, there's not even music.
Oh my god.
Scary.
Because it's cool.
So true.
Oh my gosh.
Sarcan, thank you so much for the favor.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Stay in the plain select screen for a bit starting the
mission yeah okay i'll try that thank you good luck thank
you keep the f22 but i imagine oh oops that's not what i
meant to do sorry uh we'll keep the f22 for story for how
cool and everything is um but um but but what should i do
the
because we should be locking on things inside.
Or am I all guns, baby?
No bombs?
You're fine?
Okay.
Mint!
Mint, what, what, what?
I can't read it!
Thank you for the super chat!
Do I have any 3DS Ace Combat?
Oh!
I can't... I think I have one.
I can't remember.
Not right now, sorry.
Just survive.
I'll survive.
XMAAs and standard missiles are enough.
Alright, I'm trusting you guys.
You guys know best.
Thank you also for all of your help and guidance through
this game.
I really, really appreciate it so much.
So...
Mission 18!
You will survive Minto 01!
I'm going to take some, I'm going to eat some chips for a
second.
I'm starting to get really hungry, so.
The result in the defeat of the wild enemy was brought chaos
to our continent.
Although we are from different nations and of different
races, we have fought, suffered, and died together.
It's not stress eating.
I didn't have lunch.
Today, we shall gather for the final battle to liberate our
beauty for the UCA continent.
Victory will be ours.
We shall return peace to our people.
We will win back our freedom and our future.
everyone now let us take back our shattered skies
it's so funny when i when i was crunching i couldn't
understand a word he was saying
good luck make go save the world
megalith destroy all indicated targets Blitz Blitz Blitz
Admits the blue skies A link from past to future the
sheltering wings of the protector Sky Eye here All Mobius
aircraft Report in
Oh my friends, look at us go The Mobius squadron!
That's too cool!
Thank you for the silver chat!
Sorry I couldn't read it Guys,
oh shoot I forgot to shoot it I bet.
All right.
All teams are on the 13th floor.
But we can't get to some control room to help it.
It's an electronic lock.
We load the position until the generators are destroyed.
So hurry up.
Here they come.
Don't let the enemy get through panel K.
Aldman, use your handgun.
So I have to defeat these guys before doing anything, I'm
guessing?
No?
Wait, yes?
Oh my gosh, dang it.
It's optional but advisable.
Holy cow!
Oh shit, no, I lost Tony.
Did that miss?
Ugh, yucky.
Thank you.
Hard enemy radar spike.
Right on tone too, so I thought.
The music is insane.
I shot two down even
how many more are there just feeling I'm like getting all
into this but I wonder if I should head over to the they
said there was like some sort of generators a lot That
needed to be done or something?
Someone help me!
Mobius 1, banded behind you.
Right now nobody!
Good job, meow!
You just say meow?
Oh, I got it.
Good job, meow!
Max power!
Mobius 1, banded behind you.
I can't tell what is the...
This entire thing is Megalith?
Are we moving north now?
Are we going?
Hard enemy radar spike.
We headed over?
Check six.
Excellent, yeah.
Oh, I do have two left.
I could just take them out.
Oh, I need to switch.
Those rockets just keep coming.
missile shot trashed yeah it sucked we need to get inside
megalith we're gonna keep dancing like this
radar lock box two fox two yes
okay Okay!
We got him!
Nice splash, thank you.
Yeah, there's like a yellow one up top, but I don't think
he's...
I don't think he's part of the yellow squadron.
I think he's just a... Oh wait, no, just kidding.
Wait, wait, actually, I can't tell.
Oh, no, he is.
Where'd he go?
there's
just a little more maybe oh all right so how do we do this
now we gotta get inside um things are actually quite
confusing i think tunnel oh my god where's the tunnel at
take your time okay follow the a I do
not see a tunnel.
White lines.
Like these over here.
Like...
Is it down on the ground?
Gotta get low.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god, this is gonna be so hard!
What the hell?
Okay.
Um...
No, stinking way.
Is this for real?
My hands are so sweaty right now.
Okay, we're gonna, we're gonna, like, circle back, you know?
We're gonna make a big old circle.
We have 13 minutes, so maybe it will...
It'll be okay, who knows?
Holy cow, okay.
Oh my god.
Love looking into the ocean.
I mean, into the sun.
Oh, I see it.
Okay, right there.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, this is, this is already a...
Okay.
Pull up, it says.
No, I can't.
Use the yaw.
Yeah, okay.
Good plan, good advice.
Okay!
That's one!
Kato 2 block off the elevator.
Don't give up our air support, we do something.
I'm not, I'm just gonna ignore them.
I'm literally ignoring them.
Sorry, everybody.
Some of you may die, but that is a sacrifice that I am
willing to make them.
Okay.
Yeah, we're taking it nice and slow.
I'm not.
They do their job.
so you can do yours.
They're counting on me to destroy these generators.
Okay.
The music is too cool.
When it tells you to pull up, it's so stressful.
Am I the right one?
Mobius 1, Fox 2.
They've got us trapped.
The enemy said, can't all be.
A path of retreat's been cut off.
Alright.
This took me so many tries.
Good luck.
Thank you!
Surely one here.
We can't hold it any longer.
We're pulling back.
No, don't give up, Yeet.
Don't give up, Yeet.
Okay, I didn't see a final tunnel.
Am I crazy?
Come in.
Where are you?
We'll be annihilated soon.
Have they blown up their generator yet?
This one is from the...
side.
Oh, okay, okay.
Like over here?
The green arrows.
Oh, I see it, I see it.
Okay.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
What would I do without you guys?
Holy cow.
Wait, I don't see it actually.
Oh!
No, wait, I don't see it.
Wait, I don't see it at all.
Wait, is it this?
I'm sorry, did they just update the time to be 20?
30 minute long mission?
Close enough.
Sure, yeah, whatever I did it.
Okay.
do I have to go back in the tunnel or is this is it now like
open middle
tunnel okay okay thank you
they give you 30 minutes to listen to the music obviously
duh surely no other reason the meteor shower I all my all my
friends are just of circling the area which is kind of cool
i like that part wait okay
big turn surely this can't take 30 minutes um oh that is not
the middle shoot hold on sorry
how far does it send me back sky eye here all mobius
aircraft report in mobius 2 on standby
on standby preparations are complete ready for battle all
aircraft follow Mobius one
there is no team engaged I should have I tried to commit and
I and I it was a mistake Mobius one engage all teams are on
the 13th I...
I...
But we can't get the sub-control room to open.
It's an electronic lock.
Reload the position until the generators are destroyed.
So hurry up.
Here they come.
Don't let the enemy get through.
Okay.
I just
gotta get over it.
I gotta get over it.
Hard enemy radar spike.
Box one.
I gotta get over it.
I feel more I don't feel as frustrated as you guys probably
think I feel like I feel more I feel like I'm like an idiot
I feel like an idiot that's all
I know what to do now.
So I don't feel as, you know...
You're not an ace if you've ever crashed in a tunnel run.
Maybe?
Yes?
Yes.
No way we can fly in that crawl space.
That's how I feel.
Why are we sending in planes?
It's ridiculous.
Why are we doing this?
The asteroids won't hit you.
Don't be afraid.
Yay!
Oh, there's still more?
How do you level out your flank?
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Let's get that guy.
Bullseye on that flanker.
How many are just the two left?
Wow.
Only the tunnel will hit.
I know.
Only the title will hit me.
Oh, damn, it missed.
Oh, that's so late.
It's no use.
You can't get any closer.
Maybe we don't need to get that guy.
Maybe we can just get this one.
Locked on.
Maybe.
Oh, man.
The shortest tunnel is the middle.
Oh, no!
What?
When did that happen?
Where's this guy?
Yeah, it worked anyway.
That's crazy.
These missiles are crazy.
Okay.
You can have them.
Sure.
You can have them if you want.
Radar lock.
Missed.
Damn.
Just a little more.
So low.
Uh...
Splash one.
Okay, guys.
Try number two.
At least the music is so good.
Oh, I don't know why I'm going so low already and so slow.
We're so far out.
Destroyed?
What did that just say?
No, the middle one.
The middle one, please.
Thank you.
I feel like I did so good in the first part too.
I'm so mad.
You know?
Like, I got through all of these and then in the last second
I, I choke.
So frustrating.
No, we are on the right guy.
There we go.
One passageway six.
Engo two block off the elevator.
Don't give up our air support, we'll do something.
So scary.
My hands are so sweaty.
Accidental aerobatics?
Nah, I meant to do it, probably.
Wait.
Which one did I just take out?
But no, that was the middle one.
Wait.
I'm confused.
I'm just gonna... I'm just gonna do what I did before.
Tunnel start!
Yeah!
I
really started psyching myself out.
This is hard.
I go.
Okay.
Just stay cool.
Like a cucumber!
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can't hold it any longer.
We're pulling back.
No, don't give up yet.
It's my out of heart.
It would be exploding out of my chest right now.
Probably.
You try doing this.
Can you be patient with me, please?
I'm just gonna do what I did before.
The exhaust vents are open!
Hurry up!
The planes are plunging in any minute now!
Alright!
Back to where we were before!
We'll get those panels open!
Don't let those pilots die!
Which one is the middle one?
The green one, right?
The one that has the green arrow on it?
Do a barrel roll!
Okay, hold on.
I need a second.
Oh my god, I need to breathe.
let's follow the green arrow okay all right i'm gonna go get
some more water i'm gonna get water i'm gonna get water oh
my god i can't stop shaking like craziness okay hold on i'll
be right back
the pressure is too real the pressure is so real oh my gosh
oh my gosh Back in my day, these blue supertats were for
flushing.
Hi, Jeffrey.
Calm, cool, like a cucumber.
Why not?
I'm not calm or cool at all.
Ah!
Wait, so was the...
Was the tunnel open before?
I just, I don't think I saw it.
Okay.
No, it wasn't.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay.
Alright, the green one.
Yes.
Yeah, the center line.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got it.
I'm just...
I'm so nervous.
My friends!
Thank you for all your help!
Flying into the sun.
It's very dramatic.
Oh, I just...
destroyed it.
Yummy hero.
Oh my.
The once familiar scent of burning jet fuel has long since
faded away.
Random collusion.
Thank you.
What was once Yellow Squadron's runway is now just a local
highway again.
I write this letter to you now.
I know it must have brought him unexpected joy to have an
opponent like you.
At the end of that meaningless war.
to believe.
Heroes really do exist, so I just only you, the pilot who
shot him down, can confirm this.
Me.
And so, I write to you.
J-Lacon, thank you for the gift.
Superliminal, thank you!
Oh my God, yeah!
The harder the mission, the more you fail, the sweeter that
mission accomplishes.
It took me 10 to 15 tries to finish A's combat 5's tunnel
run.
Oh, geez.
Absolute cinema!
Thank you!
Oh, yippee!
Heroes really do exist, so we just saw one.
I mean, she's coming home!
Like, no yawing challenge run.
Of course, no, I did not yaw once.
If you saw it, you didn't.
This song is awesome.
Boiled again for the first time!
Satellite imagery!
Shirley and Karaoke.
I will add...
This is a sub...
A bob.
Oh, so far.
This is our snake eater!
Amidst the blue skies, a link from past to future,
sheltering the sheltering wings of the protector.
Mintyus 1!
Yeah, I do know Ace Combat 0 is before 4 and 5, but I'm
going in release order.
Congrats on being the Ace Combat 4!
Proud of you for saving the world.
It was so fun.
The...
Oh my gosh, I can't even remember.
Hold on.
The last mission is just so funny.
It's not even that difficult.
It's stressful, but it's not difficult.
Like all the yellow squad are just like, they're pretty
chill actually.
Yeah, it's very tense.
Yeah,
because we took them out, right?
The new recruits.
So sad.
We just took out a bunch of newbies.
Obius, what is my favorite Ace Combat Ace?
Yeah, me too.
He's so cool.
Good job, Gamer, thank you.
Another playing game.
Oh, another playing game for the league.
Oh, thank you!
Crimson skies, high road to revenge.
Jetsus thrust is risen.
Congrats on clearing the game!
Ace Combat 8 is coming out!
Yes!
So if you have the chance, please try playing other Ace
Combat series.
I will!
Thank you!
I'm getting ready for Ace Combat 8.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes.
What's this?
I'm excited.
Nah!
Thank you for the pig!
This guy's, I used to sing it to remember my ocean after
graduation.
She loved Ace Combat like you, but she never got a chance to
play all due to circumstances.
Maybe one day she can play them all.
She's such a dedicated passion person, I will always miss
her.
Aww.
I hope she gets to play them too.
far to go congrats me to ace thank you oh
feels so good yeah
we saved the world everybody we saved the world that was
awesome What was your favorite plane and why was it the
F-22?
Besides like the...
The...
Mission 1, all aircraft, weaponry, and money obtained.
Wait, I want to see...
Pilot Binto my kamiyoshi, congratulations!
Thank you!
To the newbies, Mint has done concerts on the USS Hornet,
which is the basis of the carrier in Ace Combat E!
Yeah!
One of them at least.
Hold on, sorry, I'm gonna skip this.
Because I want to see...
Wasn't there one plane we hadn't unlocked?
Oh, whoops, wrong name.
Yeah, sorry, narrator kid.
Oh, look at that!
What's the difference?
What is the difference?
skins i'm not even i'm looking at the stats i'm not looking
at the i wasn't looking at the plane
wait that's the one we just looked at my favorite plane
let's get for the a10 actually
I like this one too.
I like them both.
This one, the coloring reminds me of Rex.
I really do like the F-16.
But the F-22 flies so well.
It's kind of crazy.
F-16 is a classic.
This guy's got the reversion of OG from Ace Combat 4.
This is the jazz version.
5 has a remix.
And Ace Combat...
Infinity.
Watch the Ace Combat Vibes trailer for a preview.
We can do that, and then I'll go eat dinner.
Let me pull it up.
We'll pull it up.
Ace Combat Vibes.
The music is so good in this game.
Oh, so good.
My favorite thing about playing games with really great
soundtracks is after i finish the game i go to find and buy
the i go to find and buy the soundtrack you know oh dmca for
the trailer oh oh no wait really
i don't want to get i don't want to get struck
maybe watch muted yeah give me a second
we can watch it with this bgm i guess We can watch it with
this BGM.
Because
I did that immediately after Ace Combat 7, I went and I
bought the soundtrack.
I was like, I need this.
You can mute it for us.
We can always search it up ourselves.
Oh, you should listen to it?
Okay.
If you guys don't mind me just reacting, no sound.
Here we go.
You're all listening.
But you guys won't be able to hear it.
This was uploaded 14 years ago.
Listen.
Merska.
The yukes.
Nagase!
I won't die.
Wow, we have like actual models and stuff now.
We've come so far.
Pretty lady.
Yeah, sorry, it's the Japanese subtitles, but they're
speaking in English.
Uh-oh.
Yukto-banian just declared war!
Number five.
Oh!
It already looks so good.
Not history repeats.
Once again!
Grim!
The Yuktabania!
The way they say it is so funny.
Grim.
The Demon Legends.
Nagase!
What?
The person talking!
Wow, this is a long trailer.
They?
Rosgris.
The demon of Rosgris.
I've never seen a stupid fairy tale come true like this.
Their unsung war!
Title draw will begin.
No way!
Can't take it all the way!
Can you take it all the way?
This is amazing.
Holy hell.
That is hilarious.
Take it all the way.
That was the last song I expected.
That was great.
I'm excited.
I don't know when I'll be able to start five.
Sooner rather than later.
But, um...
Yes.
Thank you guys.
Boobius!
9-3.
Thank you!
You made your first steps to become a great fighter pilot,
Minto.
Even the best players started by the ground.
Thank you very much for dedicating the saga and sharing with
all of us the passion.
Thank you for making this dream reality.
see you in the sky thank you so much thank you for the pink
you did great today me though we're always happy to cheer
you on through frustrating parts and retrying tough levels
thank you i really appreciate it like i said it's just been
it's a really stressful week for me so because i just have
so much going on so my my tolerance is a little lower for
certain things you know so sorry if i got a little
frustrated i had a day i had an angry cry and then i came
back.
It's not even that they're like frustrating, or rather that
they're difficult.
Like the ones that I was the timed missions.
It's like just that they're so long.
They're so long.
But that's okay.
We did it.
I beat the game.
Yippee!
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you!
Good job.
Thank you, Magnete.
Project Awakement.
Everybody's asking for Project Awakement.
I hope I can get race combat, though.
Congrats on the well-earned win minxer!
Thank you, Darko!
This AOL 13's goal still haunts the sky, forever searching
for a worthy pilot to smooch!
Relax, eat some yummy dinner, have a great night.
You too!
They got big budget after the success of base combat floor.
Oh, that's awesome.
If anything, the game saved the series after 3 was a big
failure.
That's so crazy, though, because I hear such great things
about 3.
Is it one of those types of games that wasn't like
appreciated at the time but like aged super well and people
realized how good it was later on as a player thank you for
the toy first mission btm ace combat five was used as
entrance music for the tokyo 2020 olympics opening step no
way cult following hmm maybe i guess i mean if if it sold so
terribly here or I mean there it makes sense why they would
want to gut the story and be like just sell that plane game
in the west just get rid of all the stuff that is super
expensive to translate just sell the game so we can make our
money back you know if you ever play three get the Japanese
version I've definitely heard that but man someone recreated
an entire war
Doing these missions in VR is one hell of an experience.
Oh, I can imagine.
What the heck?
Kid me is seething that you got megaliths in two tries.
Present me is smiling like a maniac.
Thank you.
Megalith was so funny.
It felt kind of...
It felt... It was so epic and...
an anti-climactic at the same time because I was just going
like two miles per hour.
And I'm like, Phil, I hope you're feeling better.
Thank you so much for the Pritha Gap there.
Thank you.
Puddle of Mud is a really good song to find out.
I know that song.
I didn't know it was associated with Ace Combat in any
capacity.
Thank you so so much so so so much so so much so much wait i
think i missed midori thank you it's called before clear
thank you for the akadono my message i don't know i don't
know what kind of gif gif member How do you say notification
in Japanese?
How do
you say notification in Japanese?
Should I say?
Notification.
Oh, too much.
Thank you, thank you.
Kokuchi works?
Does it?
Ah!
Jay, thank you!
You're a hero.
Mint A stone.
Thank you!
Alert.
Kokuchi is more public notification.
Oh yeah, I've never thought about it.
Do these even count as notifications?
What do you even call this?
Whatever, who cares?
Cover when?
we'll have to do the song in uh in karaoke puddle of mood
puddle of mood
thank you so much everybody i am hungry so on that last
mission warm me out and i have more to record i have let's
plays to record so i will go do that Thank you, everybody,
so, so, so much for helping me get through Ace Combat 4.
And you guys should all have a good meal, too.
And enjoy Wolf Among Us.
Yeah, I will say nothing about it on stream so that you guys
can see my whole reactions and feelings and thoughts in the
Let's Play.
We'll be out later this week.
So, thank you so much, everybody!
Atsumi, go eat it at the show!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you!
Bye-bye, bye-bye!